23 year old jeffrey gonzalez died
thursday morning when a driver ran a red
light that driver said to be an impaired
juvenile so this happened at windmill
and torrey pines in the southwest part
of the valley and that's where we find 8
news now reporter madison kimbrough
where a memorial is now growing for
gonzales
yes people have been stopping here all
this afternoon leaving mementos as you
can see from this memorial and trying to
comprehend what happened thursday
morning as 23-year-old jeffrey gonzalez
lived nearby he was struck by a teen
driver believed to be trying to get away
from police
thursday morning clark county school
district police tried to stop a chrysler
minivan for possible drug activity near
sierra vista high school the driver sped
off and then a short time later that
driver ran a red light at windmill lane
and torrey pines hitting 23 year old
jeffrey gonzalez's car neighbors who
witnessed the crash say speeding is the
number one problem in this area i heard
a lot of yelling people yelling for a
long period of time prior to putting the
signal in a few months ago this was a
kind of a dangerous intersection it's
had a lot of
accidents i just saw parts of pieces of
the cars you know still on the road even
after they left i can't even recall how
many accidents there are on tory pines
and windmill
at least over a dozen that i've i've
seen it in county police released that
the driver of the minivan is a teenage
boy who showed signs of impairment
annabel terry lives across from where
the accident took place and worries
someone will crash into her backyard you
know every day i do worry because people
do go speeding down behind windmill and
i'm afraid that you know
somebody is going to go through that
wall one day who knows you know the
driver now facing dui resulting in death
and reckless driving resulting in death
charges because he's a juvenile his name
and age has not been released
now we reached out to the gonzales
family to send our condolences obviously
they were too upset to talk but there
have been several people to come up to
this memorial you can see across the way
leaving flowers and candles and we
learned that jeffrey was a graduate of
sierra vista high school where he played
baseball reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now